Moi, ma spécialité, c'est vraiment la politique
J'adore en parler J'...suis très à l'aise avec ça
J...J..J'ai ça dans le sang quoi
Faux
Alors, peut-être que c'est dans ma nature mais
quand il y a une discussion politique avec des gens à table
naturellement, moi j'arrive pas à être dedans.
Je suis à l'extérieur de la conversation.
- Dans ses discours, c'était cohérent.
- Oui et non.
J'ai l'impression que mon corps s'efface du moment présent.
(B) - La crise en France ça fait 30 ans qu'elle est là et on n'en parle que maintenant.
(A) - Non, mais d'accord, sauf que ce que tu dis, "ça fait 30 ans", oui mais sauf que elle a toujours existé comme tu le...
*bruit de chaise pendant qu'ils continuent à débattre*
Pourtant je tente des trucs, j'essaie de parler mais
quand je parle les mots ne s'intègrent pas dans le débat.
(A)  - On fait rien pour eux, tu vois.
(B) - Oui mais qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ? Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire en même temps ? Les mecs ils font rien de leur vie tu vas pas les aider...
(A) - Oui mais c'est ça que je...
*débat inaudible, ils parlent en même temps*
(Norman) - Ah bah justement y'avait un reportage sur le...
(A) - ...conditions de vie ! Les mecs ils sont...
(B) - Ouais ! Bon...
(Norman) - Hey, moi j'ai vu un reportage... un reportage...
*ils débatent en fond*
Alors du coup je dis plus rien et toute la soirée j'adopte le rôle du meuble.
(B) - Et donc toi le communautarisme ça te dérange pas?
(A) - Bah, ça dépend.
*boing*
(B) - Ok bah on est d'accord
(B) - Tu peux me passer la poêle s'il te plait ?
(A) - Tiens.
(B) - Je vais partir sur un steak.
Pourtant je m'y connais un petit peu en politique, j'ai mes petites opinions...
mais j'ose pas les exprimer avec des gens parce que...
J'sais pas, j'ai peur de dire de la merde.
Ma plus grosse phobie de l'univers
ça serait que soudain tout le monde se tourne vers moi
et qu'on me demande :
(A) - Et toi Norman au lieu de jouer avec le chat c'est quoi ton avis ?
(Norman) - Euuh... comment ça ?
(A) - Bah c'est quoi tes convictions sur le conflit israelo palestinien ?
(Norman) - Euuuuh...
Vu que la politique c'est des sujets vraiment sérieux,
importants, graves, et tout,
quand il y a une discussion comme ça on dirait que, on n'a pas le droit tout à coup de dire un truc pas politique
(B) - Non mais on est d'accord aussi qu'il faut des épaules pour gérer une crise comme ça...
(Norman) - Tu veux une petit peu de sauce encore dans tes pâtes ? Il en reste un petit peu.
(B) - TU TE FOUS DE LA GUEULE DE QUI LÀ ? ON PARLE DE LA CRISE EN FRANCE ET TOI TU NOUS FAIT CHIER AVEC TES PÂTES !
(Norman) - Du coup tu... tu manges nature ?
... tu veux même pas un petit filet d'huile d'olive ?
... même pas un petit peu de sel ?
En plus c'est con parce que les mecs qui font des débats comme ça
ils essaient de se convaincre l'un l'autre
alors que jamais tout d'un coup ils vont tomber d'accord.
- Personne ne devrait avoir le droit de tuer des humains ! La peine de mort je suis juste contre !
- Nan mais reconnais que dans certains cas c'est quand même bien de punir les gens.
- ... ah ouais. Putain j'avoue c'est clair ! J'suis carrément d'accord avec toi mec !
*rire* - Prend un petit bout de pain ça fait plaisir.
Alors je laisse parler les gens, je dis rien, je...
Je suis là mais je ne fais rien
Mais si vraiment j'en ai trop trop marre et que je propose de changer de sujet
ce qui n'est pas très grave,
on me fait cette remarque :
(A) - Mais tu vois, c'est ça que j'essaie de...
(B) - Ca m'intéresse pas de...
(Norman) - Hey les mecs ça vous dit pas de changer de sujet ?
ça fait une heure qu'on parle de politique...
(B) - Non mais regardez-le avec son magasine là !
dans son petit monde, son petit "confort d'occidental", posé sur sa chaise
ah il y a pas de soucis ! Le paludisme, ça te dit rien ça non, t'es dans
les magasines ! Voilà !
la mode, peut-être ?
(A) - Mais range moi ça, là, putain fait chier.
(Norman) - Désolé...
En tout cas ça nous empêche pas d'aller voter c'est super important
et même si vous êtes pas trop sûr de vous vous pouvez au moins voter pour le candidat qui vous ressemble
enfin... pas physiquement evidemment.
A VOTE !
*musique lourde*
Si toi aussi tu vas faire des efforts et aller voter pour les présidentielles,
tu peux partager cette vidéo sur ton mur facebook
ou rejoindre ma page facebook, j'en n'ai qu'une seule.
*La Marseillaise*
*un chien aboie, la musique s'arrête*
Et vive la République.
*hurle*
*rigole*
Comédien.